what would you say is the is the is the
greatest sports game of all time hmm
well it's NCAA football I have to pick
the year
versus Madden oh yeah yeah but there's
more teams you get to College you know
fight songs there's more pageantry and
the players turn over they're only there
for Four Seasons so you have to the the
the so you know it's that there's it's
more Dynamic so you like variety versus
so what was the last one 2014 maybe it
was
and you don't like FIFA and I like look
FIFA's incredible I just look I'm a
college football fan they give you that
fantasy if you like if you like European
football soccer Fifa is incredible yeah
I love that game too
have you been paying attention to the
game design of that world of those
worlds yeah and the thing people I think
with those kind of games
it is really like we're racing games
Forza put up there I love Forza
um play them all when you are have to
recreate something that's real in the
real world say it's cars or it's sports
games everybody knows how it should work
that's that's a really difficult task
when people know how it should work then
you're going to balance it for single
player the multiplayer parts of it
um they get very very competitive
and you know in many respects you're
forced to put out a new version every
year
and
I say forced in quotes because they're
you know you count them as big updates
but it's a very it's a much more
difficult development process than I
think
um
people understand
and how hard those teams work I know a
lot of people who do it and I think they
just do
I've enjoyed them all I buy Madden every
year yeah so yeah every single year
yeah they do refresh it there's a
feeling of freshness I don't know what
that is you know look there have been
years where it feels like less was done
and more was done but I enjoy it every
year